one and your live chat
very much
good evening members and officers
welcome to this full council meeting
this evening thursday the 31st of march
2022. welcome also to our youtube viewer
viewers at home we're streaming this
meeting live as well as recording my
name is councillor mark hurd and i'm
chairman of malden district council
please note that by being present at
this meeting you're giving your consent
to being recorded
members if you wish to speak on any item
please indicate and i will invite you to
speak at the appropriate time
you may remain seated if you wish but
please reference page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions clear
and concise
please note that the sound recording of
this meeting is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore when
invited to speak turn on your microphone
and turn it off when finished
and please avoid approaching the the top
table here in front of the cameras as
there are live feeds that are hazardous
and affect our streaming
i also would like to advise you that the
fire exit is the door behind this top
table
gender item number two is apologies for
absence could i have apologies please
miss bird
yes chairman thank you apologies have
been received from councillor boyce
councillor hall councilman morgan and
councillor schemes and councillors thank
you chairman and council
thank you councillor and councillor i
think yes
apologies chairman sorry okay thank you
very much
i will now move to agenda item three
which are minutes of the meeting held on
the 24th of february
and we're asked to note that they are a
true and accurate record
these are presented for accuracy only i
so moved do i have a seconder
councillor maize thank you if any member
wishes to raise any matter or of
accuracy that they need to indicate
their wish to speak now
i see no may we agree these by a cent
thank you very much
we move on now to agenda item 4
declarations of interest this is to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraphs six to eight
inclusive of the code of conduct for
members
those members are reminded that they are
also required to disclose any such
interests as soon as they become aware
should the need arise
throughout the meetings do i have any
declarations please counselor
maze thank you mr chairman non-pecuniary
uh interested in item 10 as i live in
austin thank you thank you very much
councillor darren
thank you chairman uh as a member of
essex county council i have a
non-pecuniary interest in the majority
of the agenda
however the essex county council
monitoring officer has advised me that
as i am a deputy cabinet member at the
authority he thinks i do have a
pecuniary interest
a declarable pecuniary interest in item
13 so i will leave the chamber at that
point
thank you for that councillor fleming
thank you chairman and non-pecuniary as
a member of essex county council i also
want to state i won't be voting on item
13. thank you thank you very much cancer
stamp
yeah same for me i'm an essex county
councillor um i won't leave the chamber
i've got a non-procurement interest and
a gender item 13 but i will stay and
listen but i won't be voting chairman
thank you very much that's noted and
councillor edwards
uh thank you chairman i'd like to
declare non-bacuner interest item nine
i represent this
council at draper's farm sports club
which is the property of mdc thank you
thank you very much any other
declarations
no okay thank you very much
uh we'll now move to item five
these are questions in accordance with
procedure rule six three of which notice
have been given there is a question from
mr tom kelly uh mr kelly i see you i see
you there um would you like to read your
would you like to come forward and read
your question please
thank you counseling could ask you to
put your microphone thank you very much
there you go i might pollute the
atmosphere you're fine go there
can i just say before i read this this
is prompted by what happened on limerick
way
when that
there was no electricity
in the planning application according to
the offices
and therefore
pipelines if you like had to be drawn
all the way from washington road all the
way down from retro
to limebridge to provide the electricity
that's that's partly where this is
coming from thank you
and legal advice be sought
via qualified planners
to investigate
if necessary community facilities and a
stress necessary
such as health facilities
included
in the planning application
must be prioritized
and given the same importance
as energy
water
sewage or telephone connections
and legally in place
prior to the commencement of house
building by developers i'm pretty sure
you know where i'm coming from on that
okay that's with the public perception
okay thank you very much mr kelly
um
members a full answer has been supplied
to this question and is available in the
supplementary pack um leader did you
wish to respond to this
uh well chairman i'm in your hands i'm
happy to read the answer out so remember
the public can hear it um if you so
desire chairman
members
yes okay yes please
thank you chairman it's rather long um
answer but i i will
um hope my voice lasts for this
uh
in response to counts uh sorry mr
kelly's question um the council's
professionally qualified legal and
planning officers have been asked for
their advice in relation to mr kelly's
question
it is important for everyone to
understand that the system that the
council is forced to work with is far
from perfect and it is appreciated that
public expectations of what should be
charged for or prioritized in terms of
the sequencing of a development are not
generally the same as what the what the
council can achieve whilst applying
planning law
planning obligations as they are legally
called which include developer
contributions from things commonly
called section 106
and
the abbreviation is s106 agreements or
section 278 highways agreements are
legal undertakings between the council
and or the county council and a
developer and or land owner that are
entered into to mitigate the impacts
a specific development proposal could
otherwise have on the local area
they have the effect of making a
development that is otherwise
unacceptable in planning terms to be
acceptable and therefore enable the
granting of planning permission
the council does not have however the
legal freedoms to merely charge what it
wants to or even to stipulate
prescriptively when such facilities
should be put in place instead if the
local area is to receive any money from
development the council must follow
strict legal tests set out in the
community infrastructure levy
regulations 2010 as amended and policy
tests set out in the national planning
policy framework or mppf as it's known
these are they must be necessary to make
the development acceptable in planning
terms they must directly relate to the
development and they must fairly and
reasonably relate in scale and kind to
the development
in applying these tests when drawing up
the legal agreements the council has to
accept that it cannot seek money from
development to address deficiencies in
the existing provision nor seek all the
money upfront so that works by the
infrastructure providers can take place
before the development starts
funding from a developer tends to be a
contribution towards the cost of
delivery rather than the full costs and
so service providers have to bring in
other funding or bid for monies to
deliver upgrade works
what the council must do instead on the
recommendation of those asking for
funding is insert trigger clauses into
the section 106 agreements that makes
the developer pay once a certain number
of homes are occupied that is to say
when the developments occupants are
starting to draw on local services and
have an impact and in respects of the
bigger developments like our garden
suburbs this may well be split over
several years until they are built out
and occupied
it is due to this complexity and
importance that malden district council
monitor housing developments frequently
with site visits whilst cross-checking
information with building control and
council tax to ensure developers pay
what they owe in accordance with the
triggers in the legal agreements we are
also prepared to take formal action when
the developers fail to pay which i'm
pleased to report does not happen very
often
as many people will be aware work on the
local development plan ldp review is now
underway it will in the context of more
housing growth in the district be
revisiting what infrastructure is
required in addition to that already
planned for in the current local
development plan so that development
that takes place in the district
contributes fairly
and reasonably as required by the legal
test towards the burden that it creates
locally
we will be considering as part of the
review whether there are any other ways
we can bring forward infrastructure
through development that does not rely
solely on 106 agreements s106 agreements
by working with the infrastructure
delivery partners
to conclude under current legislation
the council does not have the powers to
force developers or service providers to
have the community infrastructure
upgrades in place before a development
is built
more than members and officers will
however continue to work tirelessly to
ensure that the infrastructure
associated with the current ldp comes
forward once the triggers are reached
within the terms i have outlined thank
you chairman
thank you very much indeed
we we now move on to agenda item six
chairman's announcements um i have none
uh i'll go on to
gender item number seven which is the
the minute book
uh and this is 7a and this is to
consider the recommendation from item 6
of the southeast planning committee that
met on the 9th of march 2022 and i'm
going to call on vanessa bell to present
the recommendation
councilor bell
thank you mr chairman um the
recommendation
is that the council agrees that all
future meetings of the southeastern area
planning committee be held at birmingham
crouch town council offices now mr
chairman i'd like to add an amendment if
i may
just to preempt some of the inevitable
questions which will be around
financial implication of that so
i would like to amend this to say that
we would like
the it department to
come to burnham office at town council
offices
to undertake a scoping exercise
and to produce a report containing
costings which can be presented at the
next council meeting
so that is my motion with the amendment
thank you
i'll second that thank you
right okay thank you
okay members so
we have had uh
we have had that uh motion put forward
it has been seconded by
councillor mays
councillor
fluker yeah thank you chairman i'm look
i'm grateful to the chairman of the
committee of what she's trying to do to
move this forward but at the end of the
day because
the greatest respect you can't amend uh
a recommendation from a committee
without the committee agreeing it but
chairman you know this traditionally and
not everybody may well you may not
remember but traditionally the south
east area planning committee has always
always
always met at malda burnham
and it's always been a great committee
and we've always prided ourselves
chairman that we've always had more
people come to those meetings than you
ever see at any of the meetings in
modern and it's great for the people of
burnham now i understand the cost
implications gem but you know what i
would say is that we agree
we agree this recommendation
um
on the basis that the it infrastructure
doesn't cost should we say more than a
thousand pounds because chairman i am
confident i'm confident chairman that
the mileage uh expenses saved in
relation to us not having to travel
across the district to come here will
soon outweigh that cost and and i think
we need to move this forward because the
people in burnham desperately miss this
great event taking place once a month
in their uh in in in their village town
thank you
thank you cancer fluke i'm sure they do
miss that
um councillor bell um
are you happy with that
amendment long as we're doing everything
lawfully um forgive me for not
understanding procedure truly but
counselor fluco said we just really need
to move this forward so so
so would you would you like to withdraw
your original
uh motion
the amendment sorry amendment yes i will
say because it appears to be an unlawful
amendment anyway i'm happy to thank you
for that and you're happy you're happy
with that council maze yes i am right
okay councillor channel
um thank you chairman um uh yeah i was
one of those that voted obviously for
the recommendation but the question was
put
could we do the streaming and because
council has resolved that all meetings
must be streamed so we have to go with
that and i think at that time it was
felt it could be but
um council bells probably it's very
right to question now about or seeking
about the financial costs that may be
applied
my understanding is um that from i i did
do a bit of background work as well it
may well
be in excess but i mean we have officers
here that could um actually respond or
confirm that might be more than one
thousand
so that's now on the table the one
thousand and it's not just about members
saving mileage actually for me it was
about residents who may want to come and
people living in bradwell or rashford
um when you think they have to travel
here we're talking over a 30 well it's
above 30 mile round trip i don't know
the exact mileage but i know what it is
for me for coming from where i do
but i do know that having the council
said streaming must occur we must apply
that now i'm very well aware and i don't
know about technology but i have raised
it there's something called an owl
which apparently can be utilized which
is relatively cost effective and might
do the job but that's not a matter i can
say will do the job because it's another
member who told me about it who's
obviously got greater details of
technology that i have but i i support
the recommendation counselor bell but
obviously subject to knowing that we can
do what council said it would do and
must do to have adequate streaming
facilities which you put on the table
that we need to look into that thank you
right okay so we are yes we are indeed
back to uh this uh this recommendation
uh that's
subject to the cost council stamp yeah
thank you chairman and correct me if i'm
wrong when did the council actually vote
that it would um southeast would move to
um modern district council offices
anyway because i don't believe that was
taken i think it was a measure under
covered
so if you actually take that on board
automatically this council should
provide the provision that's always
happened in burnham on crouch for the
dingy and for burnham crotch residence
members so i take on board there may be
an additional cost which there will be
an additional cost but council fluke and
councillor bell and um and and the
leader is is quite right we do need to
actually take it back and the cost
really is minimal compared to the
democracy in allowing people and
residents to speak on planning
applications and if you take on board
that with doing revision of the ldp i
think it's even more critical than it
ever was so i certainly support the
motion that it goes back to southeast
planning regardless of the costs thank
you chair
yes if if this was
if this seems like we've got another
thing on the table now
if this was um if this was agreed under
the covered restrictions uh it was
agreed uh about the uh the youtube
screening in council that was agreed and
that's something that we have to have um
in burnham if we're going to do that did
you want to come back on that i do
because that's not the point the point i
was actually making it was never agreed
to move permanently to moulding district
council offices then burnham chairman
but i've taken board what you said but
that's not really what i meant no i
understand that i understand that
mr leslie can you help us out on this
certainly help out in terms of costs uh
an indicative figure i've had from the
um ict team are about 5 000 pounds in
terms of equipment if we look at the
quality of the equipment that's out here
because obviously if we're streaming
youtube i think historically we've had
question marks around uh the ability to
hear those that are speaking the quality
of the videos in fact we've got a new
camera as well that we hope to make
a better experience for those watching
in terms of youtube we don't also know
the wi-fi quality out there and all the
different parts that we need to put in
terms of the ict infrastructure and the
it team haven't done the visit really to
assess that out there so i've flagged
that in terms of the costs that i've
been given as well at the moment and
also we would then re-prioritize some of
the projects that the it team uh are
working on so if that helps in terms of
possible costs that we that we perhaps
are aware of at this stage
okay cancer fluka first
kevin i mean it's rather ironic that
we've got uh on the
agenda tonight we've got the commercial
strategy because i would have been
heartened to hear the 151 officers say
perhaps this cost could be partially met
by burningtown council because i'm sure
chairman that they would be
thinking absolutely wonderful that they
were the first to stream their council
meetings because they could use this
equipment as well so you know i think
there's a great opportunity here not
only for us to deliver that service back
to the people of uh of the southeastern
area
area
but also support the town council so i
think we should proceed with this and i
think in the great scheme of things it's
a great investment chat
as i said you may stand up if you wish
councillor durham next
uh thank you chairman the the owl device
that counselor channel referred to is is
actually that
it's used at essex county council it's a
mobile device it looks like a bigger
alexa
actually and it's taken from committee
room to committee room plugged into
a laptop
it has cameras and it has microphones
and it automatically detects who's
speaking and turns
their the camera to them so you can see
remote meetings so really you'll pinch
yourself
and they are the princely sum of 900
pounds each
okay thank you councillor helm
thank you mr chairman i just wanted to
make known that you have no traveling
expenses from me to the meetings here to
chelsea to burn them or anywhere else
don't climb it i never have thank you
okay thank you so councillor bell um
we're back to the original um
proposal which hasn't been seconded yet
you can amend it of course
i'm sorry i can't hear you
thank you
i'd have to get in place um oh not sure
sorry could i just pause there counselor
thompson
sorry too many likes i'm sorry answer
darren your lights on thank you
um thank you sorry this is
totally off please chairman but i was
wondering if county already used these
things is there any possibility of this
being lent one to trial it
because i would hate to spend the
princely sum of 900 pounds on something
it doesn't actually do the job and if we
knew it would i'd be more than that
i mean that got the sights it's better
than five grand
well it it
it may well it may well be that uh that
the recommendation may be that we look
into this
perhaps
so do you have do you have a new
recommendation my new record thank you
mr chairman yeah my new recommendation
is that we look into the potential of
the owl streaming device to
support the initial proposal
so that is uh uh that is a proposal it
is seconded by councillor white
yes mr dodson
thank you chairman i just just wanted to
say i think the next meeting of
southeast planning committee is
wednesday the 6th of april that it's
scheduled for i would be
surprised given
what um
mr leslie said that the the it team
would have the capacity to put this in
place
before then just to flag that up okay mr
leslie
oh sorry i thought you were indicating
okay all right through you mr chairman i
really don't think we're expecting it to
be in place in right
time so the proposal is that this is
that this is investigated and
looked into and that's been seconded by
councillor white uh
i understood that it had
no
counsel why did you second that
i thought i seconded that we were going
to um look into purchasing the owls uh
or at least see if we could borrow one
for the next meeting
um so just to say the it team have
messaged me to say that they all support
teams but we may have a problem with
youtube streaming so i think perhaps
as a whole perhaps the it team could
take away as a bigger picture in regards
all the ict infrastructure and perhaps
come back with something
um i like obviously
perhaps some dabber have a look with all
guards of your capacity around what what
is achievable what fits with what
systems we have
if they could perhaps do that
investigation that that may help us
answer yeah councilwoman
thank you mr chairman surely um a quick
email twisted county council would
suffice because if they use them
regularly they'll know exactly how they
work and how effective they are i would
imagine you could get this done for a
meeting in a week's time i don't really
see a problem why not
and the other thing is i would imagine
if they're faulty you get 28 days to
return them if they're not suitable
right well i think that uh
i think we are it's kind of confusing
the issue now we need to decide members
whether uh or not we are going to to
trial this or not
um so counselors
that we look at the potential of using
the hour to stop and we do it right okay
all right so members are you happy that
we look at the potential of this device
this owl
and uh see what we can do with that yes
right okay can we agree that by a cent
that is agreed then thank you
right thank you members
agenda item eight
yes counts
but we still haven't dealt with the item
on the
on the minute book that we will move to
burnham
that has got to be voted on one way or
the other we can't just say oh we'll go
up and do something different and try
all things we have to still deal with
that item yes or no
i'm happy to do that but i don't i don't
see that it happening until we until we
have the information but i'm happy to
put that uh i'm happy to put that to to
council uh well i'd like to propose then
that we moved the southeast uh area
committee back to um
burnham and in the meantime we we
resolve to um decide whether we're going
to use now or not or how effective it is
to put one in for trial or loan or
something else well i think i think that
will fly in the face of what this
council has decided uh that we've
decided that in order to youtube to
stream them on youtube uh that we have
to hold it
somewhere where you can do that and at
the moment you cannot do that in burnham
because we haven't invested we haven't
we haven't investigated
that
right um
so
i'm confused
right okay members i think uh i think
what is happening it
i think what is happening is that uh i
think there's too many questions to be
asked at this stage um the
the actual recommendation is
that southeast area planning committee
recommends that the council agrees that
going forwards the southeastern area
planning committee shall be held at
burnham on crouch
town
so we're happy to agree that without
this extra information
thank you
right well i i think that uh
council what has council has agreed is
uh that we that going forwards uh the
south eastern planning committee shall
be held at burnham on crouch we haven't
specified when
uh but it says that going forwards so
councillor duik
thank you mr chairman
the officers have had three weeks to
look at this since south east
put forward that proposal why have they
not done anything in three weeks and a
node asking for it to be put back for
later dates and everything else it's
nonsense if a proposal comes forward
from a committee or the council or any
other part
of this council
by members that should have been worked
on and i failed to understand the
excuses now well we don't know anything
about it they've had tons of time to
find out why has it not been done thank
you chairman
mr answer that one
so in terms of the indicative costs um
the rit team have put that at about five
thousand pounds what needs to be done
in terms of the uh availability of staff
to go out and look and sort out the
infrastructure and analyze what wi-fi
capabilities are out there that's
something that the team would obviously
have to have to do and re-prioritise
other work so in terms of the costs we
have an indicative feel of the costs but
what we don't have is an exact idea of
the ict infrastructure around that and
how that sorts out the wi-fi side of it
so that's something we could obviously
look at going forward if that's what
council
decides but we would obviously need a
budget
in any case to put in the hardware for
that
right okay so the so the uh the
agreement has been that we will look at
this we will look at this device uh it
isn't uh uh
there isn't a definite time uh when this
should be done uh but we should
certainly have a reply by by the next
council meeting i would have thought
yes cancer stamp
chairman just to maybe try and help the
officers or the it department if they
would like to contact the mayor or
myself we can give them the name of rit
company we do have one in the sticks
and they would be able to help us
help the officers to look at the
capability and the capacity that we've
already got in the chamber and we do
actually have hearing loops we do have a
huge tv and i'm sure that um i can't
speak because it would have to go to
council but i'm sure something can be
done to actually take this committee
back to where it should be chairman and
i think where there's a will there's a
way and i think there is a will and
hopefully we'll have a way thank you
cancer
chairman going back to the dreaded owl
the whole point of the owl is that it's
a movable thing it's it's about so big
it can be moved from place to place it
can be taken down to burnham and use of
their meetings it could be used in here
it could be used in any of the other
offices
if the directors wanted to hold
a hybrid meeting it can be used for that
i mean moving forwards because we know
we're going to have more hybrid working
something like that that can be moved to
exactly where we want it i would have
thought would be invaluable
well i think that's we've agreed to move
forward councillor white
thank you mr chairman yeah and with the
it i've been working remotely from home
and all i have is a um ee mini hub which
costs however much a month and that
provides um
wi-fi to up to seven devices so i'm sure
that would uh stream youtube i know it
streams work meetings on teams really
well so okay well we we have uh
i'm streaming sorry okay
right okay
and youtube streaming and from what i
can see they seem to be doing a demo on
youtube about the owl but that's
suddenly kicked in so apologies for that
but
perhaps we could just look into that
yeah i think we've agreed to scope that
and i and i'd like to move on now
right
agenda item eight minutes of meetings
of the council
we moved to a gender item eight minutes
of meeting the council and i propose
i propose that we note these these are
district planning committee on the third
of march
southeastern planning committee on the
9th of march overview and scrutiny
acting as the crime disorder on the 10th
of march and the central area planning
committee on the 16th of march can these
be noted by a cent
thank you very much
agenda item 9 is a notice of motion and
in accordance with notice duly given
under procedure rule 4 councillor lagan
is to move
a motion duly seconded by councillor
nunn councillor lagan please put your
motion to council
thank you chad do you want me to read
the motion
okay so the motion is to ensure best
value and scrutiny is undertaken are
part of the council's park and
waterfront assets asset management and
associated operational processes but the
scheme of delegation to the director of
service delivery open brackets dosd
close brackets be amended amended as
follows
17 asset management d to negotiate the
terms of new leases including interim
and initial rent both at market rent and
in those cases where existing tenants
have a statutory duty right to call for
a new lease on expiry of the current
term the director of service delivery to
provide options to the town war members
who will review and determine the review
of the existing issuance of new leases
up to an annual value of fifteen
thousand pounds and a duration not
exceeding seven years
small e provide detailed report option
for determination by the town's war
members as the above in relation to
leases with an annual value in excess of
15 000 pounds but not exceeding 25 000
pounds or 10 year in excess of 7 years
but not exceeding 14 years
sections d and e the results of the
recommendation by members to be ratified
by strategy and resources committee
44 operational issues relating to a
parks and public open spaces including
waterfront and keys
to develop proposals and options for
letting and leasings on buildings which
must be referred to the local ward
member review group for determination b
formal recreation areas the development
of proposals for the letting of stalls
kiosks and any other operations there on
including lettings of funfairs circuses
and other short-term lettings shall be
determined and submitted to the local
war member group for determination
c to provide proposals to the local war
member review group on any community
assets including builders structures etc
or on any potential change of use
intended for determination
that's the motion chair
thank you council again this motion has
been proposed by yourself and has been
seconded by council and none
are there any questions i'm sorry could
i just add a couple of bits to this
about the motion um i
apologize for not standing up um are you
talking about an amendment no no i just
want to just talk to the motion because
i've read the motion but i want to put
some explanation to help members and
sort of explain why the motion's there
and the importance of it
um first of all i just need to let
members know that this motion was sent
in
with with a lot of thought set behind it
it was sent in uh following council
processes and the motion itself was
amended by officers without any
consultation with myself or the seconder
now i feel that's very very unfair
okay so that we wasn't even involved so
the red good lines you've got through
that was done by officers my motion
initially wasn't that and i can
understand why that happened but i would
have i thought out of respect any member
that
submits a motion should be contacted if
you want to amend it or add stuff to it
so i think that's something that needs
to be pointed also point out i'd like to
thank you for allowing the motion
because yesterday the emotion was going
to be pulled
yes it was i've got an email here the
process was going to have the motion was
not going to be accepted it was going to
go to pg a
so i'm grateful for the chairman to make
a determination along with the leader
now when you look at this motion you
might think christ we want to take over
you'll run another council that is
absolutely not the case
i want to be absolutely clear this is
not members trying to take over officers
work this is members working into
collaboration with officers
so if you sit there in your seats and
think about who put you in that seat
who voted for you and the reasons why
you're sitting there is the members of
the public who entrusted you
to to manage the assets to work with the
town to develop take on different
aspects but to protect the things that
we've got but also look at innovative
ways of working and protecting the
district
so why say memp ward members and town
members if there's an issue about malden
mulder members need to be involved if
there's an issue about south minister
southminster members need to be involved
if there's an issue about a hey bridge
heybridge members need to be involved to
do with what the motion's about this is
just simply collaborative working to
give members input and determination in
the decision-making process
we know that these are not time-bound
we're not going to be members forever
but other members are going to come in
and sit in their seats and they're going
to be standing for the same things that
you stood for when you started your
election campaign this is not political
there is no political driver and you
shouldn't think of this as i've got to
vote this way because i've been told you
vote the way on the motion however you
see fit as a human being but think about
what you're actually doing you're having
the opportunity
to help change and shape the future of
things in your district in your area
i think it gives input to members with
no politician political it's an
inclusive motion it's everybody it's not
just mobile members saying we don't like
some of the decisions that have been
made this is we want to be involved in
the decision we want to work
collaboratively with the offices because
it's not a dig at the offices
it's not that and finally it's it's not
operational it's strategic because if
you start looking at leases and you
start looking at events those things are
brought up well in advance so it's not a
five minute fix so you're not going to
be time bound by it because we we need
speedy and agile decisions we meet every
month at strategy and resources and this
still feeds into that
so i think members i'd invite you to
support it because i think it's
important for the people of the district
that they see us having input in that
decision-making process
thank you chad all right thank you
council again
um what i would say what i would say is
uh where there where there have been
changes uh this was to to clarify uh the
motion it was not uh meant nor did it
actually change
uh change the
uh change the motion um i agree that it
would have been a good practice uh to
let the
the uh
author of the of the motion and the
second
uh to know that those had been done uh
the reason that that i allowed it was
because i felt that there was uh
inadequate time uh to tell you whether
it was going to be withdrawn or not so
that's why that's why i decided to to
let it let it in
right members so you've uh
you've had
answer none
you made a comment there to chair about
withdrawing your decision to withdraw
them yes i'm sorry though those are you
how would you be able to withdraw
emotionally it's been accepted as a
motion and has been tabled on a public
agenda
that was a slip of my tongue there was
never any intention of withdrawing this
uh i will say i'm sorry those are my
words and they're incorrect
right members any other questions
counselor thompson
um thank you chairman i i appreciate
where council lag and council and nana
coming from but
i think what we've all got to accept is
that all of malden district assets
belong to all of malden district's
residents
not the town councils not the parish
councils after all they don't actually
consult us with what they do with their
parks village halls what have you and
they're their assets belonging to their
community
and that's how they deal with them
and i think we can't look quite so
narrowly you know say the prom park will
say riverside park
it belongs to all the residents not just
the people who live nearest to it
and those
you know whether we do or don't want to
let a kiosk and what it's for that
affects the whole district not least as
to whether we can afford to keep these
parks and what have you running
i'm also concerned that you know what
about other other areas what about you
know the tollsbury lose you know that
that's i said earlier didn't like
chairman you know that's that's a fun
thing that comes up now and then
why should the ward member
why should one ward member have actually
it's quite a lot of power and i think it
is very close to executive powers i i
you know if the parish council wants one
thing and the ward member wants another
thing and then the district council
can't afford whatever it is anyway
i think we're going to be forever
tweaking this if we start it now and i
actually genuinely think it should be
referred to pg a if it goes anywhere at
all
so thank you
cancer fleming
thank you chairman through you i just
wanted to find out from councillor lagan
where he's the sort of driver for his
concern whether it lies with the
corporate projects working group um
i'm just interested to learn
you know is he concerned about the
governance of that work thank you
thank you chair through you no i'm not
i'm not concerned about the governance
of that i
my driver for this is to have more
inclusive decision making and input at
member level
it's not any it's not any other any
other reason for that and i think that
this is a motion that stands alone
there's nothing to stop other members
bring emotions forward if they wish on
different aspects because we're all
entitled to that but it's it's purely
about having
and i i hear what council thompson says
but when you're looking
who knows the areas that they stand in
the best the best who knows that the
members that have been elected to serve
that so with that knowledge and that
experience you can bring in because it's
a collaborative process with officers
with other ward members and my initial
thoughts was bringing a couple of others
but then it's bigger than being her so
here i didn't really want to do that
did you want to come back on that cancer
flowing yes thank you chad does this not
sort of take up the work of the asset
management working group that
unfortunately hasn't met for some time
but i'm assured that it will be
uh restarting soon and i think actually
that's where the problem lies is that it
was that was kicked into the long grass
and had that been meeting regularly
and reporting back regularly i feel that
we perhaps would not be in this
situation thank you
okay cancer civil next
uh thank you chairman uh as council
lagan explained in uh his background to
this motion
all these things go through strategy
resources anyway and when it comes to
uh the decisions that are made yeah they
are always made in consultation with the
leader and the chairman of strategy
resources so therefore if we were to see
something that we didn't necessarily
agree with i'm sure officers would
listen to what we've got to say
in terms of the ward member so for
example
little totem has sawyer's field
which is a recreational ground owned by
malden district council
and it's designated as public land and
it's it's maintained by modern district
council therefore if this motion goes
ahead
if anything came forward about sawyer's
field it would be me who made that
decision
yeah that then is questionable because
surely i live in little tottenham i'm
going to make it immediately i've got an
interest
and that interest should really preclude
me from making a decision on little
totem yeah
so therefore
it's better if it's wider
and at the moment i see things working
and they work well in terms of the
delegated decision and they work well in
terms of the working group so i don't
really see the need for a change
okay cancer fluke next
yeah the overarching thing here is is
the scheme of delegation
because
you know if you change it for these
specific areas then you might as well
change the whole
scheme of delegation
and and i think council is absolutely
right you know
delegation is there for a purpose
and if members aren't you know if if
something comes to a committee and the
ward member isn't on that committee then
they can attend and i'm sure under most
normal circumstances the chairman allow
them to speak and put forward but of
course this is this is all to do with
the scheme of delegation
personally i don't think the scheme of
delegation should be visited i think
it's right and popular and it's fit for
purpose otherwise we would be
continuously bogged down in everything
you know the members involvement in
everything and we can't have a small
cohort of you know i'm sorry but we
can't have a small cohort of members
dealing with certain things because
council thompson's absolutely right you
are on this council to represent all of
the residents and particularly in
relation to all of the assets that are
owned collectively by the residents so i
think that's one thing so chairman i
think as
as this motion stands i i don't think i
can support it i think maybe it might
need to go back to corporate governance
working group it might need to go back
to pga but german i just wanted to ask a
question through you in relation to
uh 44 a
and in particular the last word
um it seems to me chairman that if this
group
um
wants to be formed the local ward
members review group it appears from 44
a that they will actually be determining
things now
i'm sorry that's taking away the scheme
of delegation taking away the input from
other members and taking away the input
from committee and council and for that
reason chairman i cannot support this
and i hope other members don't think
okay thank you
i will come back to i will come back to
you cancer leg and counsel the china
next um
thank you chairman may i remain seated
because i've got yes
thank you
um
councillor thompson actually has um
touched on it and i will be frank when i
did read this um i did think was this
introducing perhaps some form of
executive powers
in terms of and it was what council of
lucas touched on because there is the
word determination used
and once you hear that that seems to be
giving a rather executive function to
the local ward member review group for
determination
regarding dne and i hear what council
lagging says actually i do have
sympathies where councillor lagan may be
coming from and i know it's say it's all
wards but actually it's so specific it
does say in d and e we're referring to
town ward members and i see that
actually referring to more than
malden members
town or um burnham on crouch i don't see
it necessarily pertaining to my ward of
mailand so i recognize that in the amb
of 44 it mentions ward members only the
concern i have about this chairman and
council of luke has touched on it and
delegation actually councillor siddal
has
i know that throughout the constitution
there's probably other areas that this
might impinge on and i'll give examples
such as emergency powers that have to
come into play at times in which that
will be with the leader and the chairman
of the council or the leader of a
committee
now that would mean we'd probably have
to revisit that as well because i could
see there'd be in fact a bit of conflict
with that issue and in in terms of
what's here so i'm not trying to be
negative but i do think if if this was
to be looked at it's not just in
isolation this matters i think it does
go beyond just the delegation
and that would have to be wholly
revisited we'd have to have terms of
reference for a local ward member review
group because when you're saying for
determination to me that's executive
powers and actually chairman through you
i would be grateful if perhaps the legal
officer could give a view
in terms of does she consider perhaps as
any executive powers
indicative in this um or not i think
that would be helpful to members bear in
mind council lucas comments counselor
mrs thompson's and perhaps thoughts that
might be going with other members
thank you chair um yeah in terms of the
constitution any
group as as council wagon has called it
um wouldn't normally have the powers you
would have to set up a subcommittee for
one of a better description to give them
those and full council would need to
give them the powers to determine and
make decisions and then and then report
back it couldn't be just a group similar
to a working group as they wouldn't have
the power to make
decisions
okay thank you councillor stamp what's
next
uh yes thank you chairman um i've
listened to what everybody said um and
especially council lagun i think what
he's actually suggesting is more
cooperation with the officers and i'll
give you an example
and it was from one of the working
groups that i was on i it was a working
group i didn't i couldn't attend
and then i attended the following one
and the minutes were recorded when i
think i'm allowed to say this because i
think it was uh on um it will be on
for members to be able to read
i'll just i won't go specifically but an
asset in birmingham crouch
was going to be totally removed off the
council's list for repairs or up for
renewal because of the process and that
most probably would have then been
delegated to the leader and the leader
the chairman of strategy and resources
without any consultation to any of the
ward members and we would have known
nothing about it so i totally understand
where council lag and saying i totally
understand what the other councillors
are saying but i think it would only be
common decency to include in some shape
or form the ward member whether it be in
this format and i won't jump on council
leggings but what was put in red was not
canceling lagon's words he didn't say
lord
local ward member review group that was
written in by somebody else so i think
we really need to be careful about this
motion rather than all vote against it
it could either be deferred or it could
go to pg a but i think the idea is is
that members are consulted ward members
are consulted
thank you and i and i actually do
support the the the reasons behind this
motion because it actually then gives us
not the power but the the skill to
negotiate and talk for their own assets
within those communities if you don't
want that relevant member to say sit on
another community sit on another area or
whatever because i can understand about
an interest or clean your interest or
whatever but we do know our areas
chairman we do know them and i hope we
do otherwise we shouldn't be standing
and sitting in these seats
okay thank you cancer stamp counselor
durham next
yeah thank you very much chairman i
totally understand where councillor
laguna is coming from and i applaud his
his effort to ensure
that the local members have an input
into things happening within their
within their particular ward and that is
absolutely the right thing and
everything should
probably possibly done to ensure that
that is the case but it should be
through collaboration
we have to remember
that in this council that constitution
council is sovereign
no decisions can be made
unless it comes through council unless
we're going to change that
we cannot really be having other groups
smaller groups of members given
effectively executive power to make
decisions on behalf of full council
so what i'm saying is that absolutely
there should be collaboration
but the we have a committee system that
is how we decide to operate this council
and we have full council where the
decisions of the committees are ratified
and that is chairman
how it should stay but i totally
understand councillor lagan and
councillor nunn's
views and would support those falling
short of the measures that they they
propose
okay um
i will come back to you councillor lagan
councillor swain
um yes thank you chairman i'm
i'm a bit nervous about uh trying to
change um constitutional arrangements
because they're
always very complex and have all sorts
of ramifications
um and uh
the the main thrust
mentioned has been made of the strategy
resource committee and the
corporate projects or the asset
management working groups i think we're
talking about something further back
when
um
ideas proposals are at the earliest
stage um and not necessarily major
things but
quite small ones which at the moment
just go um are automatically dealt with
under delegated powers and
the important thing is that um
um
members relevant members are informed
consulted about what is being proposed
so there is some
possibility then for them to
take action through some committee or
working group or whatever but
the problem i think tends to be that um
this consultation is rather sporadic
and in a lot of
of the smaller issues such as leases and
so on
um it's
done completely under delegated powers
um without any cognizance by by members
so
the
the key thing is
for
members to be consulted um about
anything that affects
the um
assets
yeah in their in their area
without any
indication that they should have any
sort of determining
power at all and i'm not sure quite
because of the terminology using this
where where this stands legally
and i i would need to um have much more
guidance as to what whether this is the
right legal terminology for what
and what um counselor lagan wants or
whether the way it's worded actually
um
gives a completely um uh wrong idea
okay thank you cancer fluker
thank you
let me come back and
kevin the more the more i listen to this
the more slightly confused i am i mean i
picked up on the word the determination
and local ward member review group and i
understand that these might not be the
words of the proposal of this motion
so i mean
sorry germany are you with me no i'm
just saying yeah yeah so i mean that
that concerns me enormously really about
whose motion well we know whose motion
is but we're not quite sure whose words
they are so
tim and i you know nobody likes to have
a cop out but i think on this one
chairman we've got to try and look at
what you know what's the best way to go
with this
it's always very very difficult when
something like this is put on the table
as a motion because we don't really get
the the full intent and understanding
the officers in parts to council so
my view is and i'm sure the proposal of
the motion probably won't like this but
if
if chairman this could be referred back
to pnp um to
uh is it not strategy and resources
nobody said pgn so if it's referred back
to pgna and the report goes to pgna but
that report chairman is a joint report
between councillor lagan and councillor
none and the officers so they can decide
exactly what they want to put in front
of the committee and then miss holmes
can then look at the constitution to see
how it dovetails into that then we can
have an informed report chairman going
through that committee and then it can
come back here and i think with all of
that information chairman i think the
council legend
will get an answer
it might not be the one he wants but
he'll get an answer chairman and that's
a great long proposal don't ask me to
say again but i think basically back to
p p g but i want these guys involved
with the officers bringing forward the
report thank you sorry council i'd like
to go back to council lagoon thank you
chair um i will stand on this one
because uh strange enough i'm gonna
agree
yeah hang on
yeah
agree with my friend councilman um yeah
the this is the danger when motions get
amended without consultation
so the wording
okay so the word it is key i'm not
scared to put motions in i'm not scared
to say we want to change the scheme of
delegation or scared to go and say we
want to change the constitution we carry
on doing what we do we get what we
always got and i think i was talking to
an officer today who was inspirational
in giving me their time
and views and there was another council
i think it was finland that actually
basically rewrote their constitution
and their standing orders and they made
it very clean they made it less
legalistic they made it easy for people
to actually understand for some of this
stuff you you look at it and you think
it's like a bowl of spaghetti how do i
untangle that you know you've got to
have the specific skill sets to be able
to do that so i had no problems at all
with what council lafleucher has
proposed about putting that back i i
still feel the scheme of delegation
should be challenged i think it should
be changed because this makes it more
collaborative and how we get the wording
i think what council of fluker actually
said is right
but i think we need to we need to do
something you know we've had about a
couple of years of of hell and and
stalemate and
blockers put in our way so start to make
things happen for the people get the
people who put us in the seats to have
the faith in us to make the decisions
that we can
with officers who are professional
people and i speak as an ex-officer as
well chair
so yeah if if my um second accounts are
none is is agreeable with that i think
what counselor fluke has said um on this
very very very rare and monumental
occasion i will agree with him
so
so would that you're seconding his
proposal counseling right are you
withdrawing okay and would you like to
withdraw the first the first motion
uh with support of my second day i will
yes
yes i'm happy to withdraw the um
proposal as its table because it bears
no resemblance to the one that i
seconded anyway
okay uh i i will i will say again that
uh uh that the the the the body of the
the motion
uh
hasn't changed the the spirit of it
but mr mr mr dodson
thank you chairman it's it's more than
the spirit wasn't changed there was no
wording changed to the motion
for example the words local ward member
group for determination were included in
the original motion the only change was
that it was highlighted in red
in the constitution
to show what was withdrawn where the
changes were which was a line shown
through it and the new wording shown in
red
there was no change other than that
right okay so members i i now have a
proposal did you want to
cancel channel well yes chairman i i did
um and i just wanted to highlight um
that actually uh council mrs thompson
did mention about perhaps going back to
pga in her when she in her opening
speech and what i would say is just to
be clear i think it's been good to have
the debate here tonight but that was the
original intention because the
constitution when you do have something
that falls under the remit of a
committee such as this did
um
regarding the issues that are here in
terms of the constitution because it
will affect the constitution
it wasn't ever to withdraw it was to say
to refer to pga in the first place
that's good we've been had had this
debate tonight
but actually um the the committee could
be the very good place
for it to go back to because then it can
be looked in its entirety
and get a proper consideration through
that committee coming back to council so
it was never intended to remove i want
to make that clear or to withdraw it was
always in the first instance because it
does affect the constitution in more way
than one from my perspective and what
i've understood to be the case hence why
i would have gone to pga in the first
place however the
chairman in consultation myself agreed
tonight so we've had the debate and
we're going back really but with an
added bit on to pg a where i think it
will be considered properly
answer none that being the case then
chair why was the motion accepted in the
first place
because it's a valid motion council a
number and it immediately gets it into
the public domain
because otherwise unless that's agreed
you wouldn't have it on the order paper
right members i i i do have a proposal
by councillor fluker to to take this to
pgna
that has been seconded by councillor
lagan
are you happy to agree that by ascent
right that is that will be done then
thank you
right we are now going to move on to
9b
uh this is a motion from councillor
swain
um
and
in accordance with notice duly given
under procedure rule four council swain
is to move the move emotion duly
seconded by councillor bassinger
councillor swain can you put your motion
to council please
yes thank you chairman um
i don't think i need to read out
the motion because the
the details of it are really quite
straightforward
and
it but it is an important matter i
regret having to load you with a second
motion on this agenda
um
concerning the whole process the ldp and
what what the fallout is from it
when the current ldp was subject to his
last examination in public i had the
opportunity to
make a representation to the inspector
that
when a strategic view of
malden was taken or the whole of the
area of east of england malden was
accorded very little housing
on the grounds that it is a essentially
a rural low-lying area with poor access
um and that it's only
been allocated 120 houses a year
uh the inspector asked well what would i
suggest and i set a number nearer to
120. so we ended up with 300.
um
now we've got the same situation coming
around this time being asked to
cater for at least 300 a year for maybe
up to 20 years
and what's changed well
what's changed is we have built a lot of
housing on the low-lying areas and
that's generated a lot of traffic which
makes um
the area less accessible because you've
got more traffic trying to get through
dandery and highways england are
removing the um
junctions at hatfield pebble in favor of
a new one up near whitham so
things are worse so
how does this come about it's because of
the mindless churning out of projections
by the office of national statistics
based on recent and current trends
there is no planning in it no thought
it's just allowing developers estate
agents so in the area to carry on doing
what they've been doing for the past
now added to
these
we have an added burden because of
affordability affordability is
calculated by looking at the average
house price in relation to the average
earnings in the area
um and it's from alton this is quite
relatively large and whether you take um
earnings of people who live in the area
or people or earnings and people who
work in the area it still comes out with
quite a a relatively large difference
and what to see uh these
uh intelligent range in the department
come up with they say we'll build more
houses
as if that's going to actually make
housing more affordable
um it'll have no impact i mean it's
economic nonsense
and it shows a complete misunderstanding
of how the housing market and
development market works
so how do we then
find the areas to develop all this
housing we call for sites
and we're entirely dependent on people
coming forward with available land from
people who
see a um the scope for making large um
planning gains and where developers
think the best they would best like to
develop um and this is
completely um we say
undermines the possibility of any sort
of properly planned strategic
settlement strategy we don't know if we
don't get land coming forward in in the
right places um our
menu of seven different options for the
segment strategy might have to go out of
the window and we'll end up with the
developments where we don't really want
them and this happens anyway because of
this five-year land supply problem which
isn't about land supply but about
deliverable housing
and we depend almost entirely on the
developers and that industry for the
rate of of development
the local planning authority has very
little say in it but who gets the blame
local planning authority and we find
ourselves in this position of the tilted
balance where developers um can have
even um freerain as to where they want
to um
to go for
for a development
um further undermining any
settlement strategy that we might
want to
implement and also creating further
habit for um possible infrastructure
provision
um
we've we've come up against this
five-year land supply problem and the
fact that we've had a very good
performance in housing delivery for the
recent years is ignored
this is this doesn't make sense either
and then of course when you get down to
individual developments
um
developers will try to maximize their
returns and they are short of a fairly
good return and when we try to get inc
higher level of affordable housing in it
there's always this plea about viability
viability um so it makes it almost
impossible to
make meet the housing mix that we would
really desire particularly for
the people who really do need affordable
housing
um
so
we've come across this tilted bounce but
in fact it's it's at this last stage the
whole system is geared
to to um satisfying the ambitions of
developers
at the expense of sound planning so what
i what this motion is trying to do is to
bring it to um the attention of the
secretary of state which is michael cove
i think today yeah if it hasn't changed
again um
who is
who is um responsible for housing he's
responsible for planning he's also
responsible for leveling up and leveling
up comes into this uh to as much as
malden as a lot of other places
um
and uh i want this
to get to him so that he will actually
quiz his department and say is this
really what happens
um this doesn't make sense i'm he's
quite an intelligent chat
and if we can get a response um we've
asked for a response generally but if we
can get any movement on any of these
issues i think it will be some
achievement all right okay
thank you very much um
leader um
yes sorry that was second did the motion
wasn't it yes it was yes it was seconded
by cancer passenger oh yes he doesn't
want to speak now that's i mean he's
reserving his right of reply yes yeah
okay
yeah thank you okay um just what i
wanted to say i suppose the thing that i
just wondered if ought to use the word
review and i'll tell you for why
um i'm not talking about the bullet
points or they're all honing on one of
them
um the planning white paper as we know
did come forward and this council
actually was consulted and we responded
on that consultation
and as we are aware there's been various
concerns raised on the planning white
paper
and the latest that i've picked up
although yes i haven't formally been
told
is that the planning white paper um may
well um be pulled
um that it will not um come forward um
from the minister in actual form and
that the intentions could be in what
i've read
is that actually the planning matters
in terms of things will be considered
and be done under the leveling up agenda
and indeed in um
enshrined in the law of that that is my
understanding
so therefore the consultation responses
i don't want to be revisited but the
planning white paper it did actually
talk about the standard formula and in
fact at one time there was talk about
revising that formula and having a
higher butter and my understanding all
that goes say for one item which i
understand is to do with the 106 error
at the bottom my understanding is that
an infrastructure levy is the remaining
part of the planning white paper but i'm
sure there's an officer here who can
substantiate what i'm saying or not so
the review as far as i'm aware is
already being undertaken
um and therefore i think um we need to
have clarity
surrounding the fact about the planning
white paper going and the leveling up
agenda and being enshrined in law the
legal aspects of that
and seeking then a reply to the council
cordy on the jessica and all those
measures and i think that would enable
the council to know
that definitely um applying white paper
has been withdrawn will be withdrawn and
it will be the leveling up agenda that
deals with it already within the
leveling up white paper indeed
neighborhood plans have been mentioned
and involving also about
residents in streets being involved in
street design and about place so
it may be extended further um within
that aspect that's what the latest i
have but i haven't had the formal
notification but that seems to be um
what mr governs actually indicated
um to ministers
so you're suggesting that we take out
the word review and clarify is that
correct well i think we need to clarify
things but i think the review is already
happening and it certainly was through
the planning white paper which i
understand now will not re-emerge in any
shape or form save that the thing that
will be saved and is the 106. and
everything will be done through the
leveling up agenda and the act that will
come into place but i mean um perhaps i
don't know if we have a well we have
actually only alpha yeah i'm going to
put her on the spot but
that is what my understanding is from
things i've read i haven't had actually
and i don't know if officers had any
formal notification of that these
planning magazines or house builders
things often get the information and it
does quote apparently mr gove having
said certain things
okay counselor darren
yeah thank you very much thank you very
much sherman chairman uh yet to a
certain descent i agree with with the
leader i don't think any of us expect
the planning white page to come back in
the form that it was previously because
it was far too contentious and there was
some
quite frankly rather
well strange strange proposals in it i
do think there will be a planning white
paper because the government that made
it clear that they want to reform the
planning system to a certain extent but
again councillor channel the leader is
is quite correct i think the leveling up
white paper
hinted that the emphasis on new builds
was going to be more aimed at the north
of the country rather than in this
particular area so i suspect when the
figures do come out but that we may find
that we are
um
treated slightly more leniently than
other parts of of the country but i
think it at the moment it's
too soon to tell chairman and and that's
really why
i support the change and i totally
understand councillor swain's
reason for this because we've been
around the houses goodness knows how
many times um
and uh i think until there is some
clarity in terms of the white paper
um we we perhaps should just wait and
see what happens thank you
council swain did you want to come back
on on that you've uh your um your motion
includes the word review um having
listened to what has been said
what is the suggested substitution for
uh i think we're looking to as council
channels suggesting that the review is
already under under
underway and that we should ask for
clarification uh to come back to to this
council
just substitute clarify for the view yes
clarify um and in fact you if you wanted
other words clarify the the situation
regarding the planning white paper and
the leveling up agenda uh act and reply
to the council accordingly on the
justification and what there is then in
within that motion
yeah
yes i didn't quite get all the wedding
there just clarify and refer to the
leveling up
um agenda yes
regarding the clarify or clarity
regarding
the situation in terms of the planning
white paper because i've read that it's
going to be not coming back
and the leveling up agenda
and then
and reply to the council accordingly so
it's only that bit removing the word
review because my understanding is it
started with the planning white paper
the review i've read that that is not
going to come back in its form it's not
going to be called that it's going to
all be put under leveling up agenda and
being shined in the act of that when
that is later on in the year that's my
understanding yes i think i i think i
agree to that if tara can um um note the
the wording for it and um if councillor
bassinger agrees this secondary um but
um yes whatever may be coming down the
line and however vehicle
detail it may be the fact is these are
very specific things
models formulas and so on which i'd i'd
like a response from the department on
right so so what we're looking to do at
this stage is to uh is to amend it uh
from review to clarify
is that correct yes yeah and
yeah planning white paper in the
leveling yes
yeah cancer maze
well is that seconded first of all i'll
second that right okay councilman's
uh thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
add
a further amendment um which is actually
in the form of an addition
um
in that the overall impact of the
planning regime on the local authorities
ability to secure affordable
accommodation as defined in the nppf
annex ii affordable housing
for rent
this really goes to the nub of the
problem that we have currently we have 1
539
families stroke individuals who are on
our register
all local people who cannot get houses
and how many we're building we're
building 30
we're not building the right houses for
the right people and that also needs to
be looked at and addressed within the
affordability
element of the mppf thank you mr
chairman
i have a second uh
well
can we be sure about do we have the
wording uh do we have does tara have a
wording of that yes
yes it will be added as a
a final bullet thank you right
so members are we clear about what uh
what we're asking here
we are okay so first of all i need your
agreement that we have this uh latest
amendment of
uh
councillor mays and seconded by
councillor stilts are we happy to agree
that amendment
right okay so then we'll go to the to
the vote of this are we happy to agree
that by ascent
okay that will be done then thank you
but we need to put the substantive
motion
sorry
right okay all right to move on then
yes cancer lagging sorry can i just
i just i want to just step back because
what mr dodson said i know when i get
something right i get it right when i
get something wrong i stand up and admit
to that and i've just gone back and read
the motion that i sent into mr dodson
and he is correct those words are mine
it's just the format that was sent in
didn't include all of the red stuff so
got him confused so i apologize to mr
dodson thank you
thank you that is uh uh
that is noted and appreciated thank you
right members so i'm going to move on to
agenda item 10 questions in accordance
with procedure rule 6 3 of which notice
has been given i have received none
so therefore i will go on to agenda item
11
which is making the langford and alting
neighborhood plan these are on pages
33-76
following the successful referendum in
relation to the langford and alting
neighborhood plan
this is now automatically becomes part
of the statutory development plan for
the district uh i'm not going to hand
over to the leader
well chairman i think you've said it all
so that leaves just perhaps the
recommendation i mean this is just the
last part of the process actually
um in terms of members will call the
report where we interact referendum and
now that's happened and we just have to
make sure this is all on record so the
recommendation is simply that the
council makes the lamford announcing
neighborhood plan in accordance with
section 38 38 bracket a bracket four of
the planning and compulsory purchase act
2004.
um and that's the recommendation sherman
but there's a hand waving second
second thank you cancer darren well
thank you chairman uh we finally got
there uh because this has been going on
since i was the ward member for for
langford for as pretty much as long as
i've been there
and they have tried and tried and tried
and they've had just
obstacle after obstacle put in front of
them kobe not helping so i really would
um urge up members to support this
thank you
okay i think that sounds right can we
just be sure members will agree that by
sen
thank you very much indeed okay
we move on then to agenda item 12 the
great tottenham
neighborhood plan the decision to send
the plan to referendum pages 77-232
following the successful referendum in
relation to the great tottenham
neighborhood plan is now automatically
all right well i'll i'll say i'll hand
over to the leader for this
uh okay thank you chairman um well this
this report is about um
um members um approval for the
modifications it's been through
examination and a bit like the langford
an alkene this is another part of the
process we have to go to and legally we
have to do this
and therefore the recommendations are
that the examiner's modifications be
agreed and that subject to these
modifications the neighborhood plan is
determined to meet the basic conditions
and other legislative requirements that
the draft decision statement attached to
appendix to be approved to be published
on the council's website
and the great tottenham neighborhood
plan be agreed as modified at appendix 3
enabling it to proceed to a local
referendum based on the boundary of
great chottom neighborhood area as
recommended by the examiner
second you need one
second
uh thank you chairman uh yeah
i've obviously been at bold i'm not uh
in great autumn but i've been involved
with the group who created this plan and
it is an excellent plan and the work
that they put in is commendable the
examiner's modifications were quite
minimal as well so the work that they
produced in initially producing the
report has been excellent
and i really hope that
the council can support this
recommendation for great tottenh
thank you
thank you any other questions members
can we agree that by ascent
thank you very much
we move on now to agenda item 13
commercial options for prince's road
this is on
my numbers are incorrect okay
um
commercial options for prince's road and
i must ask members who have received a
workshop on this uh uh just to warn you
please do not stray into areas of
confidentiality
um
so the purpose of this report is to
update members on the commercial options
project for the council offices prince's
roadmalden and request approval for a
feasibility study to be completed before
recommendations come back to the council
leader
thank you very much um chairman um yes
this report really is all just seeking
support to be given to feasibility study
to be carried out and that's illustrated
very clearly within the recommendations
little ones that support be given to a
feasibility study and associated work to
further explore the options for a new
office and potential development of the
prince's road site utilizing one public
estate funding at no cost to the
authority little to that the corporate
projects working group will have
oversight of this project with a
feasibility study coming back to the
council later in the
2022-23 financial year i think it might
be helpful chairman i believe we've got
an officer here tonight to go through
the port report and i think that would
also help bearing mind your earlier
statement uh not straight into the areas
of confidentiality so the officer will
do it in such a way that obviously the
matters are ones that uh um pertain to
this report and not anything that's of
sensitivities german thank you okay
thank you and i think it's um sweetly
could you please present the report
thank you can i just check first of all
if mr dodson wanted to say anything
yes thank you i would would like to say
just a few words of introduction thank
you
um
this paper is a very simple paper um
seeking member support as the leader
said to undertake a fully funded
feasibility study to look at the options
for the future of the council offices
and the prince's roadside
the study would enable members to make a
fully informed decision regarding the
offices once that study is complete and
reported back to council
the study will answer members questions
on value of the site various options for
use of the site and the options
of any relocation of the offices
those questions are not for now though
but would be answered in the feasibility
report which will come back to council
but i'll hand over now to hannah
wheatley who'll give a bit more detail
regarding the proposals thank you thank
you
thank you chair and good evening members
following the council's transformation
program and the shift to agile working
the majority of council staff are now
working in a hybrid way with business
critical staff having a full-time
presence in the office
staff use the office regularly to work
collaboratively and support development
through side-by-side coaching training
and team meetings
essential face-to-face services continue
to be provided on-site for customers who
are vulnerable or unable to access
services online or by phone
with the continuation of hybrid working
modern district council now only
occupies around 30 of the existing
council building
molden district council is therefore
reviewing the long-term sustainability
and commercial liability of the main
office at princess road
members were invited to a briefing
session prior to today's council meeting
with an initial analysis and options
were presented by the project team
this report council seeks member support
for a feasibility review to now be
undertaken to investigate these options
and the associated costs in more detail
picking up on a few questions raised
today the feasibility study will
consider alternative uses for the
existing council building
the project team will also follow the
council's internal procurement process
for securing paid services with external
contractors
the council-led feasibility review is
fully funded through money secured via
the one public estate program and this
will enable the project team to come
back to council later in the financial
year with fully costed recommendations
for their consideration
thank you
thank you
did you want to say any more leader at
all
well no when you're opening up to
questions any questions
uh i think this is a this is exactly
what's needed um
exactly what's needed um that we really
need the detail you can't make a
decision without the detail and the work
that the officers have done and will do
with this ope money will give us the
detail to make informed decisions so i
fully support this
excellent okay thank you councillor
chana
thank you
thank you very much chairman uh it is a
question and um i don't think officers
will be surprised to hear this from me
because i do actually bang on about this
it's just little too
uh that the corporate projects working
group will have oversight of this
project with a feasibility study coming
back to the council later
what i would like to know is um
the corporate projects working group
actually in my view should perhaps
report sort of regularly back to this
council
about not just this project perhaps
other matters and would that be the only
body that would perhaps have involvement
in any matters that might arise through
this process so i do think it's
important rather than waiting until the
end of what should this be agreed
tonight and then until the report's
drawn up and comes back to council we
should have some feedback from that
working group um to this authority while
this process is engaged should
everything be approved tonight thank you
mr dawson
i'm i'm not sure if it's a question or a
statement but but in either case that
that's absolutely
not
exactly i think the question was the
corporate project is that the only group
that that's going it's the group that it
would go to but that can report back to
council and provide the information
of an interim report for example more
regularly i mean not just at the end of
the process i think that's what i was
getting at and okay that's my question
really i was making the points as you
know i make and
that's what i want to know and is there
other involvement
it would be through the corporate
projects working group that would be the
reference group for the the piece of
work but
yes as outlined that that could report
back and should report back into council
as the parent
um
committee as such of of the working
group
okay councillor bell
thank you mr chairman um just firstly uh
just trust this is a feasibility study
and not a done deal but i just want to
say that the most important thing
is
the impact on our residents i won't use
the word customers because people don't
have a choice unless they want to move
um
that's the most important thing that's
really
what matters so i would urge that any
kind of thoughts decisions really have
our residence and accessibility for them
in the forefront
of
of the study thank you
i'm sure that will be the case cancer
fluka did i see your hand yeah thank you
chairman um
kevin as far as recommend recommendation
roman 2 is concerned um
the um
although i wasn't a member of the
working group i was allowed to attend a
meeting that was chaired by uh
councillor siddal and and i can't find
it and it's such a ldp wasn't it and so
remember what i wanted to know chairman
is will all members have access to this
working group because we were allowed to
listen and
with the permission and the chairman ask
questions uh i seem to remember after
about my sixth one i asked him for
permission because i'd forgotten that i
wasn't the member and he graciously uh
post dated that uh that request um so
chairman i'd like to know that and also
look this has been going on for i don't
know three and a half years i remember
when i mentioned this and absolutely
mortified uh councillor fleming um but
here we are here we are and i know a
lot's happened in the last three odd
years and uh but nevertheless councils
like sarak have managed to deliver a uh
a new leisure center for example so
with regards to uh recommendation number
two i really do think that we should tie
ourselves down and we should have a
timeline as to when we're going to come
back we've known about this course of
action for some time um
from my perspective and from my
background i don't think this first
stage is that onerous
um so and i'm not going to say to you um
a particular time so i'd really like to
ask miss weekly perhaps um
you know what she thinks is a reasonable
length of time she needs to get back to
council so i think there's two proposals
in there chairman
okay i think what i think one of them
was about members attending the access
to the uh the corporate projects working
group uh and the other one is about the
reporting the frequency of reporting
back yeah
no chairman i i think i specifically
want to know we need to have a timeline
for this report
otherwise i fear it's going to lag okay
mime is a reporting back chairman
regularly to this council as well could
you help us out on that mrs whitley
yes in terms of um reporting back to
council for the feasibility study it
does depend really on how many options
we're going to be looking at
as to how long that piece of work will
take
we do actually have a project team
meeting booked in for monday next week
assuming that the feasibility is
supported whereby we start scoping that
piece of work looking at who needs to be
involved where we do need to secure
external support and to start to build
in kind of robust costings
to support the options and the
recommendations that will be coming to
members so
at this moment in time i can't give a
time scale but i'm hopeful that once
i've had those first couple of scoping
meetings then we'll be able to provide a
time scale for when we hope to bring
that clean plaque
okay thank you cancer thompson
thank you chairman um
feasibility study and and whoever
undertakes it that will be done by
normal procurement processes and that
those people that perm team whatever um
will not be directly involved
in the development you know it has to be
totally independent so there's no bias
i'm just checking because it's something
that members have been talking about so
i'd appreciate the notes for you
chairman okay
sweetly
please be quiet thank you
i can't hear what the office is saying
so this is a council-led feasibility
study so we have the one public state
funding to use as as we see fit and so
we're looking to secure internal project
management resources to lead this piece
of work
where we do go externally for
contractors to support say quantity
surveyors or whether you need to get
their expertise brought in it will be
through our internal procurement process
and for transparency to make sure that
we combine with internal policy so that
will be done above the board
thank you chairman councillor white
um thank you mr chairman uh yeah this is
a a very simplified report um to what we
had at the working group and without
going into the confidential the uh
welcome report the first thing
was um
that it's not actually fully funded we
have to pay the 60 000 pounds back if
the development goes ahead so let's get
that quite clear it's an outgoing cost
it's not free nothing's free
um the second thing is um i think what
counselor fluke has said about access to
the working group i think this is vital
um because this is a massive decision
and i think that all members should have
an input normally on the working group
it's not that important this one is
absolutely vital for all members to be
involved so that's something i'd like to
be looked at
um because the report we were given at
the working group it sounded like most
of the work was going to be carried out
by
one organization as the united county
council and we need to be more
open-minded than that we need to go out
to the public um facilities i mean it
could just be valued simply by valuers
and estate agents you know we need to
simplify it so we get the most money
that we can out of that that's invested
um
can we be sure that it's going out to
tender and that it is going to be not
just passed on to another local
authority um i don't know how we that's
going to be reported back but it must be
reported back to members
um you know because i am concerned that
um essex homes or essex housing or
whoever they are are going to run this
show because they've helped procure the
finances so i need to be absolutely
certain how this is going to happen so
those officers could tell me how it's
going to happen and i say i raise these
questions today on what came back in
emails was totally different to what was
reported at the working group so i'm
completely confused and would just like
some clarification on those matters
please
thank you so i'll pick up the uh
procurement side of it so obviously we
have the financial regulations and
within that we have the um
procurement set out within there so it
will follow that side of it into the
constitution
around that
essex housing uh have been involved in
frank they have not been paid for that
so they have not been procured and they
have through their one public estate
capacity secured 80 000 pounds of grant
for us within that uh what would expect
to go forward as we look at the best
approach for that and then go through uh
the constitution and the financial
procurement in accordance with that
approved by council
thank you councillor keys
oh thank you check can i confirm
there'll be no cost to moulding district
council for this whatever it cost
synergy
uh we'll be looking to use the grant for
that so at the moment um
there would be no cost to the council
there i think the report actually
i think that put out lines that we're
going to use the grant um for that
and then once that the feasibility study
has been completed and decision comes
back to council
um the council can then vote whether to
take it forward or not if it does take
it forward then sixty thousand pounds of
that grant is repayable what can happen
to mdc yep that's right
yep so
yeah so what will happen at the end of
that feasibility if we decide to go
ahead it'll be 60 000 pounds repayable
for that grant at which stage then we
could look to tap into other grant
sources of funding as well which has
been happened in the past to fund any
capital development
all right thank you members uh
councillor siddall
uh thank you chairman one thing i would
like to say is is
um how good it has been to work with
essex housing and confesses county
council and they have provide their
services for free there haven't been
charges in terms of how we work together
now if the if the feasibility study
doesn't go ahead then we don't pay that
money back if the feasibility study does
go ahead then we do pay that money back
but we will only go ahead
if
the project is feasible and that's the
crucial element that it pays back it
doesn't pay back we're not going to go
ahead with it now i i i welcomed the
attendance at the corporate working
governance group
it was wonderful to see so many people
there and show you so much interest
because last year when we hold the
corporate working governance group
there were no conservatives attending
the two of the meetings
none of the conservative members
turned up
and it was just myself
counselor swain and councillor stamp who
were in attendance so it's good that
members are now showing interest
in this project
and they are if i remain chairman of the
working group after may
if
then i would welcome attendance from
other members
but it's really really important and
that was it was a very disappointing
thing that we didn't get that attendance
from those members because as we know
this project is really important to the
council and i remember
two years ago three years of having a
conversation at this working group with
council of luca and at that particular
time i wasn't particularly keen on the
proposal that came forward um and we had
a good debate about that but it is
important to the council and it and he's
right in terms of it has been on the
table for a while it's good in a way
that we did wait
because
if we'd redeveloped it now we wouldn't
have been taking into account the new
working practices and we never probably
ended up with a building
that was too large and unnecessary we
now need to come up with a building that
is right for the council
right for the district and write for our
residents and that's what i hope will
happen all right thank you councillor
fluker
yeah thank you chairman um look
i hear what the officer says about
timelines and i understand the pressure
and everything else but yeah this is a
very very important project this is our
biggest asset it's the biggest asset
that is owned by the residents of this
district it's not ours it's the
residents we've got to get this right
and we've got to act quickly in my mind
um
the next meeting of council
is the 12th of may i believe which is
the statutory annual meeting so i'd like
to put that to one side i believe the
next one chairman is on the 6th of july
and i only know that
two days before my birthday but chairman
i would propose as recommendation three
that from the 6th of july the council
meeting in the 6th of july there is a
standing item on the agenda of council
whereby an update is given to council
and if there is no update we can ask why
all the officers can explain why you
know we we are going to be you know
we're getting towards the end of the
administration now we've got sort of 13
months left of
of the municipal what the municipal
period i call it so
i really do think that's important
chairman because
the reason for that term it's not only
to focus the members mind but to focus
at the offices as well and of course
after this evening there's going to be a
huge amount of interest as you know with
residents in the district and they'll
want to know they'll want to know that
this is what we're doing so
that's my proposal i think it was more
than seconded chairman uh and and i'm
grateful for you letting me speak again
thank you
thank you before i go to any other mr
dawson did you want to add anything on
today
i don't see that being a problem at all
reporting back to the council regularly
on updates thank you council channel
well well thank thank you chairman uh
well
i don't i will agree with cancer
eukaryotes but actually that was the
point i would rather perhaps actually
have something come back even at the
statutory annual because i think um if
there's going to be the meeting on the
monday
um
if this goes ahead that
is mrs wheatley is referred to we've
then got a good period of time and i'd
be very interested in as i'm sure other
members would because some there would
be
undoubtedly a meeting in the corporate
logic working group
and i think when councilman siddall
spoke earlier he referred to the
corporate governance working group so
i'm beginning to think to myself well
why wasn't i involved and actually i
wasn't aware the corporate projects
working group had been opened up to
people the local development plan had so
um i think if anyone's going to be
invited to working groups i think all
members should have that opportunity as
well but i would like to see actually uh
something come back reporting through
the co projects working group the band
have met to council which was the very
point of what i was trying to make we
must have regular reporting on this
should it proceed
so council fluker are you uh are you
happy that we should have an interim
report for the statutory annual
the
council chan has you know quite rightly
asked for a a report at the status
january but i'm always mindful chairman
of
how that meeting goes
and i'm also mindful of trying to
cut the officers some slack initially to
get this off the ground without tying
themselves down but the overall point
that i was making chairman whether it
whether it comes back uh at the start
january or the or the sixth of uh july
chairman um is that it
it is then becomes a standing item on
the agenda and and i think both the
officers uh nodded in a agreement
chairman and they're still nodding i can
see but even without my spectacles
chairman so thank you
okay awesome right so
chairman can i just say the reason i
said that because actually from where we
are now going into july we're talking
about over three months and i do feel
there's it's need be only a short report
back but i do feel that members at that
time should get something back so they
can see should this be agreed what is
happening what the progress is and have
an opportunity to ask questions all
right councillor
thank you chairman uh yet i did misspeak
because i'm chairman of the corporate
working governance group as well i'd be
gentlemen of the corporate projects
group
and i was i was deputising for uh
councillor stilts at the ldp working
group on that thing where it was other
people's in attendance uh there is a
scheduled meeting of the corporate
project working group at the end of
april
so hopefully at that point we will get
the first review of the project and we
will be able to feedback to statute
annually in may
thank you very much
through your chairman apologies
so council so councillor
we we are um
having an amended proposal if you like
that uh that we have an interim report
at the statutory annual thank you
look i'll withdraw my proposal and then
i'll give you a new one chairman that
says that from the 12th of may the
finger statual meeting and thereafter
are all council meetings chairman that
this matter is a standing item on the
agenda and i think that deals with the
statutory annual and it deals going
forward as well you know my kindness has
clearly been overridden by others thank
you
right so counselor counselor fluker that
is a proposal it's seconded by
councillor helm uh our members agreed
with that
okay that will happen then
and next original wreck as well chairman
has been agreeing the political one and
liberty with that
proviso yes yes
yes
agreed right okay
can i be sure of that members one two
and three
all agreed to agree
thank you
um councillor durham needs to be called
back in
what i actually wanted to ask for quite
a long time was can members um be made
aware of the meeting dates for the
working group so that we know exactly
when they are
i'm sure that will be the case
yes yes yes
right the next item is questions
right okay thank you
i understand working groups are
available on
mod.gov
right the next item is questions to the
leader of the council in accordance with
procedure rule one three
um
any questions councillor civil
thank you
as councillor mays referred to earlier
one of the big issues for the molden
district
is affordable housing
ever since the sale of council houses we
know that the capital raised was not
used to build new council houses
but was used to invest in other projects
and not deliver on the need for truly
affordable homes
modern district council's policy on this
matter has not been good as counselor
mates referred to earlier
the number of applicants on our regit
has register has doubled since the first
lockdown and now stands at nearly 1500
applicants
these are local families and people
we are receiving
100 new applications every month
only on new builds can we restrict to
our district hence the desperate need to
get schemes approved with affordable on
them as we can restrict them to
properties up to the other people of the
district
when will the council introduce a strewn
strategy which has never been in place
under all previous administrations to
build and create truly affordable social
housing which is surely needed
does the leader agree with me
that mdc
should become a council house builder
in the future
leader uh thank you councillor siddal
for that question
um i may well do on that aspect and as
you'll be aware i can't go into
confidential businesses you'll be aware
you might be aware through the corporate
project working group and elsewhere what
may be giving consideration to in terms
of possibilities to be looking into the
affordable housing
i would say through our local plan
currently which as we know is under
review we do try and get affordable
housing we have the percentages through
the relevant districts or if you like
allocations within the um
uh area of the district so 30 might be
in one area but i do agree with you
regarding affordable housing hence why
also we did as you will know bring in
the the commuted sums policy as well
which would enable if we can't get the
deliverability where we may want the
community some could also help this
council to deliver more affordable
housing so there are some schemes that
you'll be aware as you are the chairman
of that
working group which i can't go into
about what the council's doing to bring
forward
possibilities of affordable housing
looking into that and for the future i
would say i'm not necessarily against
what you are saying all councils i am
aware are perhaps giving that some
consideration those that don't at the
moment
but the fair answer to that is it would
need looking into and all the details
behind it and what it would truly mean
so i can't say to you categorically yes
but what i would say to you i would
agree that perhaps we should give
consideration to it but have to be given
due diligence and put forward
in terms of a proper strategy
thank you councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman um
madame leader on bbc six the other night
the burnham ferry company discussed the
recent storm damage to the pontoon at
burnham
s r committee had agreed a budget for
the work to the pontone before the storm
damage occurred
can the leader reassure the council that
work will commence on the pontoon and
give a timeline for this
also can the leader explain why work has
not yet commenced on the pond turn
uh right thank you councillor stilts
well you will be aware you're quite
correct yes i think that might be the
item actually council stamp was
referring to about an asset that at one
time looked as though it might be
removed but sensibly through the budget
process through councillor siddal's um
ethanol committee
there was an allocation i think actually
it was in the figure of uh sixty
thousand if i recollect correctly
uh yes unfortunately there has been
stand damage due to as we know the very
unclean inclement rather uh weather that
occurred i am aware that officers at the
moment and i haven't got a further
update i'm happy to get it are assessing
that damage
therefore i can't give you a timeline at
this present time when that may go ahead
what i'm happy to do though is to get
some further details from officers and
give it in a written response to you and
also this whole council
thank you councillor shawnee
sorry thank you chairman uh
thank you madame leader
um
in may 2021 um a motion was brought to
council pledging our support for
existing
food banks and the trussell trust in the
malden district
these recommendations were agreed
could members please be updated
as to what has been and continues to be
done for our residents across the
district
how is this being supported in light of
current developments regarding
covid19
thank you madame leader
thank you very much um yes i recall that
recollection in fact we i think at that
time there was a motion on it to
actually um use this
offices for a food bank and that we
established that there's the time there
are various bodies churches together
there's also
avenues in birnam on crouch i'm very
aware of i give to a food bank locally
south minster there's various places
that do actually do that i'm also very
well aware
through essex county council that
funding has gone i'm also aware of the
town council involvement and we've also
got the caf at
st peter's hospital
so that is what's going on at the moment
and continuing and also you'll be aware
of course um collections and things that
are being done because we have now got
um it's not just our district across the
country the issue now of um the
ukrainians and the refugees that might
arrive and collections being done
and initially um goods going out so at
the moment that is the standing as i
understand it we agreed at that time
that the food bank not to be used in
these premises but to actually support
those food banks that currently in
operation and ongoing as far as i'm
aware in this current time
certainly i've given a food
through the churches in my local area
okay
yes me too madame leader thank you okay
thank you cancer fluker thank you kevin
i'll be brief because i know we're we're
tied to time i haven't i'm watching the
clock yeah well you know what i feel
about democracy german and i think
there's still a lot of members that want
to ask questions uh leader on tuesday
the 5th of april at 4 30 p.m a briefing
is taking place between the elected
board members from burnham on crouch and
the elected ward members from morden uh
this meeting is called the modern stroke
bernamon crouch
ward members briefing the meeting is
being facilitated by up to seven
officers i understand leader that you've
uh accepted an invitation can you please
confirm what the purpose of the meeting
is what issues are under discussion why
members from rural areas are excluded
and why
given the current pressures on officer
time the meeting is taking place at all
thank you chairman and i as i said i'll
take a very brief uh answer thank you
well the
the brief answer is council spoke at the
moment i can't give you that agenda
because i haven't received an agenda
this is something uh that i'm sorry um
that's what i'm giving the truth of
my understanding is these are briefings
that had been placed in the past and i
believe this has come from mr butcher
and it's re uh reconvening actually
those briefings i think did take part
past with the malden
and burnham
councillors not town councillors so i
wasn't aware of it myself but i'm led to
understand and it's so reconvening what
has previously cut been in the past and
i'm not sure who set up that up but that
is my understanding and i'll stand to be
corrected
and um that's the email i sort of got um
to brief those members again in malden
and burnham
okay council do duke next
thank you chairman
would the leader of the council agree
with me that the last couple of weeks
has seen possibly the worst spell
of the planning
control in this council that i've seen
in
31 years of council
we have lost not only lost for appeals
we have had four
lots of costs awarded
against us
the sum for that
i don't know i would assume we'll be in
six figures how many lots of six figures
i hate to think
but the worst of all
i think was probably
the
cost decision notice regarding the
planning appeal
at charlwood in stony hills
i didn't attend that meeting so i don't
know who said what but i can read what
the inspector said the inspector said in
his decision notice he refers to a
predetermined counsellor
and a cohort of counsellors who
manufactured unsubstantiated reasons for
refusal
given the serious nature of these
findings do you agree
that the councillors thought mentioned
should stand down from any special
responsibilities and additional duties
they are performing
and to demonstrate to the government
that we wish to improve our standing as
a local planning authority the matter is
referred to the standards committee for
consideration
and i say this because with four costs
decisions awarded against us in such a
short space of time
i would not be at all surprised if this
council is expected to answer serious
questions to whitehall of what an earth
went wrong because in each of those
cases the inspector
has accused the council of unreasonable
behavior and it's done on all four
decisions
and i think that we need to consider
this very thoroughly do you agree with
me lisa thank you
uh thank you um councillor dueck
what i would say is in terms of the ones
you've mentioned in fact um before that
there are others and i have to actually
ask questions and they are not when
you're referring to those ones because
there are other ones that have costs and
also i keep an eye like i'm sure all
members do whether they're done by
members decisions overturning at
committee or whether delegated
and we should have that reported
via pgna because that's a matter of
performance most definitely so that is
something that shows what our targets
are what i can say is on decision making
um as we know we're told about approvals
um this authority does not have a good
record in approving things but we're
very good on determinations in answers
your questions on the cost and you make
reference to the predetermination
member specifically
all i would say on that is i'm not
entirely
clear who that member could be but what
i would say is if it's what i'm thinking
tied up with something else that went on
a confidential paper so i can't expand
any more than that what i would say is
at the um
the meeting of the planning application
you're referring to in its determination
i don't believe that member was present
regarding the cohort that you're
referring to i presume that includes me
because
i was at the first meeting of south east
as many other members were but also the
determination of that second thing was
number of the district planning
committee so the cohort must include
this council and i can't tell you who
voted for it or not what i would say to
you is of course i'm concerned about the
costs but as you've always said yourself
um
councillor joker's chairman of south
east and very good chairman of south
east and members i believe go into those
decision-making modes believing and
applying the weight they feel and the
votes taken and i can't tell you who
voted which way and everything except
when recorded votes are done but i think
those decisions are taken with all
sincerity and considerations by the
members that partake in those planning
decisions however what i would say is
bearing in mind the nature i think what
we need to do and we've seen i have seen
inconsistencies i'm going to be quite
frank across committees i've seen
inconsistencies i would have to say i'm
going to say this
between uh local government planning
inspectors and maybe things that come
out from appeals and really what i think
we do need to have we do have mandatory
planning training for members and i
think what needs to happen in fact i'm
aware of it today that we are looking at
that and actually it may be that
something comes forward very soon in
terms of what members should do in
planning trade playing more than refresh
your courses and not having it once
every four years
or whatever so yes i can understand
there could be some bad press about this
or may have been it might be in various
planning um applications but i've been
on this couch a while and i can remember
some other bad decisions if that's how
the planning inspects to see it but i do
believe the council did it in good merit
those decisions taken by members
yeah i mean if i may just come back very
very briefly yes it will be brief um
leader i was uh
what i referred to i was quoting that
what the inspector said i did say that i
was not present at the meeting and i do
not know who said what but the inspector
is very very clear as were the
inspectors other ones about the
unreasonable behavior of mdc and i did
say some remembers decisions and some
officer decisions it's four in two weeks
it's not good news
in fact there's been um there is another
decision of another committee um i was
keen to know the decision that's come
through and i'm afraid that appeal was
lost as well
and i have spoken i can tell you
regarding planning in its entirety
i won't go into all the details because
obviously it wouldn't be right to
name
persons or whatever is happening
but planning itself i um counsel mrs
thompson and i do we meet with the
clt
and the corporate leadership team and
planning i can tell you something on the
agenda but i do believe we need more
training for all members as well and
have if you like an understanding of
policy
um or
more consistency in perhaps uh policy
application
right
members
we have reached 15 minutes i will
let me finish i will allow
uh the questions but i will not uh
expect an answer from the leader so
councillor fleming could you pose your
question please thank you actually my
question chair wasn't too um the leader
it was
rewinding to councillor fluka's
question about the meeting on monday
between the town councillors
as mr butcher is on the call on the line
i'm interested to learn
what the meeting's about thank you okay
thank you councillor durham your
question
thank you chairman and for brevity to
help a simple answer yes or no is quite
sufficient would the leader agree with
me
that the enforcement services of this
authority recently have fallen below the
standards which members can reasonably
expect members may well have will have
received the enforcement report today
there is in two parts one of cases
closed and there was the round total of
nil closed no cases closed in the last
quarter
the
open cases now run to 315 pages on an
average of three per page that means
there are nearly a thousand
cases open
so does the leader agree that this we
can we should be able to expect a better
service from reinforcement yes or no
we'll do thank you chairman may i answer
that actually you might if you wish yes
well thank you councillor darren um and
um yes
uh i will speak as well outside of this
meeting but what i would say about
enforcement
um as we know uh and planning department
as a whole and certainly through kobe we
have been um working with vacancies i am
aware um officers and um mrs wheatley um
informed me recently
members will recall during the budget
process in fact we had a [ __ ] it
wasn't this budget but during a mid year
there was
agreement to go out to get enforcement
officers or advertise for enforcement
officers because we have a new
enforcement policy and we need
to have the if you like the contingent
up to that now what i'm pleased to
report is that there are two um
enforcement
is going to be joining us
um i am aware there was for some reason
a member of staff who may not have been
able to be around
um all the while i won't go into details
of that they are now
with us but what i would say is i agree
with you totally and hence the very
reason i was one of those members who
didn't wish to see the enforcement
report stop going to area committees in
fact i was
actually um had other people in fact
i've got a feeling i won't name and
shame but it might be someone who might
ask questions
here tonight
that um
it wasn't to be and then what was set up
i can
tell you and i was involved in that as
well as other members that actually it
was agreed the area committees the
chairman of an area committee could call
a meeting for enforcement matters only
and that could be held with enforcement
staff which gave members an opportunity
because no member has the right to make
a decision or go to an office or tell an
officer what to do on enforcement it
needs a
matter of a committee i would urge those
committee chairmen
to actually call perhaps a committee
meeting so those enforcement cases can
be looked at but i am hoping with the
contingent coming up with the two coming
on board and also uh the issue where
member staff perhaps could not be
available at all times that we will see
things improve but i do agree with you
it needs to and certainly when there's
urgent enforcement cases in my opinion
they need to be followed up urgently as
well right okay i'm going to take two
more questions so can i just add to that
i know that over and scrutiny actually i
think are monitoring the enforcement
situation as well right okay i'm not i'm
not going to ask for any more responses
uh councilman mays if you put your
question please question only
i'll give you the question don't worry
thank you mr chairman thank you um
madame leader um i've received a number
of um complaints over the last few days
about from owners of residential caravan
from residential caravan parks not that
there are any in in my ward um
um about non-compliance with their terms
of their licence
can members be informed of how
compliance is monitored
how many complaints have been received
by the council in relation to
non-compliance and what actions the
council can take regarding
non-compliance given the struggle we
already have with non-compliance within
our planning framework thank you i don't
expect to respond well
i i don't want any response i'm sorry no
councillor fluker your question is
written in response
quickly leader you will have read the
cost decisions notice in relation to
land north of 16a morgan road will
remember that the members decision to
refuse this application was against
professional advice for the planned
offices in making this decision the
planning office planning inspector
states that the refuse the reason for
refusal gets nowhere close to explaining
why or how planning permission should be
refused and is unreasonable he also
states the proposal should not have been
refused in the first place and should
not have been actively defended on
appeal the costs uh against
this is really for a question okay well
i'm getting to question the cost
chairman i'll be at the question in one
second the costs are likely to be three
hundred thousand pounds against this
council ten thousand pound per household
five thousand pounds per residence given
that this was a refusal leader
uh given that the refusal of this
planning application was member-led
can you explain why no members gave
evidence at the public inquiry even
though they were invited and also given
the outcome of this and the fiscal
effect on this authority is it time that
we should apologize to the residents
chairman thank you
well i can't answer one part of that the
rest of you no i'm sorry i don't want
any uh any answers
important
i do think it's important one element i
do
i am aware
i am aware of members that may have
wished to speak at that inquiry
right okay
councillor
councillor helm and then councillor
stamp that that would be the last
question question if you remember at the
football club malden where i put
proposal to extend the question time
longer than 15 minutes or 15 minutes
restricted to the questions not the
answers and you've far exceeded this
what is going on you're the chairman or
have you decided
i am the chairman and i'm trying to i'm
trying to give members an opportunity to
ask questions i'm trying to cut this
short by saying the responses will be
given in written form but i can close
this and members don't have the
opportunity to put those questions
what is your question i'm just asking
why are you extending this because you
this council refused my proposal go over
15 minutes this is for questions to the
leader not to the chairman councillor no
this was questions for the latest stamp
and thank you mr chairman chairman would
would the leader agree with me based on
what counselor fluke has just said that
the damage was done when phase was one
was approved at six to whatever malden
road that's where i live 62 isn't it
sorry chairman but the damage was done
so that's why the appeal was successful
because it was outside the development
boundary so would the leader agree with
me
that was where the damage was done it
wasn't part of the ldp so you don't have
to answer that but would you agree with
me that was that that damage was done
then
right okay councillor white and that is
the last question
thank you mr man i'm going to just i
don't expect an answer now um
do some members being able to arrange
meetings very easily does the leader
agree with me that if members and
members of the public ask for meetings
with officers that these are organized
in timely matter secondly does the
leader also agree that even if officers
prefer home working they make a special
effort to meet with and talk to members
including um responding um to emails and
the last one was does the leader agree
with me the ons issues should be
investigated by officers and the
officers should not decide that they do
not wish to review the data because that
is part of the issue with that i've
raised with though
right
okay so
so members for those of you who may wish
to please send that sent although we
have it recorded please send those
questions to the leader and you will
receive a written answer i'm now going
to move on
to
agenda item 15 business by reason of
special circumstances
considered by the chairman to be urgent
i have
none
the next one is gender item 14 exclusion
of the public and press this is to
resolve that under section 104
of the local government act 1972 the
public be excluded from the meeting for
the following items of business
on the grounds that they involve the
likely disclosure of exempt information
as defined in paragraph three of part
one of schedule 12 of the act and that
this satisfies the public interest test
do i have a seconder
councillor thompson thank you very much
so um
miss bird if you could confirm that the
line